cute I know I was a cutie pie as a kid
but I'm a Chatty Cathy so you touch my
dick everybody's fine now well that's
what I it's a moment I leave that room
I'm going guess what I did even though
even if Michael Jackson dude pinky swear
cuz my career will be over if you tell
everyone about this bike dude no problem
soon as I get out bike I go to my
brother Mike guess what happened Jackson
just sucked me off dude well I call my
friend bro you'll never believe what
just happened you know what happened to
me right in camp I get I get fought with
my favorite story
camp counselor I know it's dark it's one
of my favorites and then I talked to my
other buddy
set this out for the people who missed
this story well they're sold on jr. yeah
yeah at home
and there there are two incidents but I
don't mean to make light of those now
there'll it's the only thing you can
well for me look he's turned out great
yeah and by the way I but but the
difference between but see there's a
difference between being in a position
where you have to do it all the time
because they manipulate your brain how
they where they rape you
yeah and there's difference being that
and being farmer but and there's also a
black guy going into it well that's true
so I wake up and the guys fiddling with
my Willie and I'm like [ __ ] boys camp so
we would be passing broke camp don't go
away on canoe trips summer camp yes yeah
so we rinse our camp you go out canoe
trips and there's one camp counsel yeah
and I remember we hold we were
skinny-dipping and he he reached under
my friend we were [ __ ] we were probably
like 11 12
okay you know old enough again I don't
remember still and he reached under the
guy reached under my buddy's dong have
said there's a bone right there
I'm I understand make it we were like
we're went from the lake sure IRA he
reached under and pointed to his taint
in English there's a there's a bone
right there he was telling story
marathon that guy reached with a hook
and just under and say you're digging
Mose here and he reached
yeah any grease toe like here's his dong
any recent when my dad goes right there
and I went that's weird like a rush red
flag weird but no one said you know but
I'm ever talking I remember we were
saying all this bad John 20 and Donnie
what how's the guy touching
the kids oh he was probably he I think
if I look back on it he's play 35 you
know he had a beard he had a beard I'm
by the way good big difference not not a
not a mean manipulative guy he was a
very sweet man
yeah couldn't catch a bomber threw a
ball at his face and he went like this
with like he was a very he and he loved
he was he was a loving he just loved
little boys not sure I'd keep going like
you noticed you know the the unassuming
soft pedophile as it were right pudgy
and all that sure and I'm not making
light of this when I tell a circus and
people suffered real [ __ ] but yes I
don't consider I know I hear you vote
for me what happened was I had friends I
was talking to and all my friends
started going this is where we're thing
by the way I didn't say this on GRE but
my other body I think back on this my
other buddy says oh I already got
molested by this other dude same kid who
was an ex-military guy in our camp and
he was still there but we didn't back
then what is this the 70s yeah I didn't
think about we until today I was like he
did but I was fried egg I never did
anything to me so I always was skeptical
about that I was like did he I don't
know about that hmm
but then again he's a camp counselor
he's with boys all the time
that's what he does red flag right so
there was always his weird [ __ ] so I
wake up and he's got his hand I'm we're
basically we all sleep together like in
big tents you know but it was like I
don't know maybe three to attend to I
remember but I remember waking up and
that guy had his hand down my pants on
white with tighty-whities I'm in the
morning is who know seven sure and I'm
and I'm feeling it and I remember waking
up going it just seemed like it was no
hold on I'm in under the top damn under
yeah but I swear to God I sort of God
it's funny when you're a kid you you it
doesn't register like I didn't register
that it was weird like I did I did then
I was like cuz I did that I used to do
that you know I mean when you wake up
and you go here you're playing with you
little Willy yeah during the show so it
felt like that and I was like this is
weird so I go to my buddy and I go to my
buddy Donny I go hey he touched my
this morning Hugh Kent was playing with
it I think I pretend I had to go to the
bathroom or something which I do that
probably pee
and he goes he sucked my dick right so I
go and then now cuz I'm slow but you're
you're a boy I put it all together a
whitey sucks and then I said to my buddy
my other buddy try to put his finger
there whatever and I go I [ __ ] I I
went alright cool
marched well I remember I remember I was
like this doesn't make sense and then
I'm thinking about it
your snare I take my name off the next
trip the next camping trip you used to
sign up the hell of the night and sit
out on the next trip right so he gives
me goes I saw you were scratched your
name off what happened then then my
friend I said I think I want to tell on
him and my friend Donny said my friend
Donny goes I feel like I'm protecting
his he goes don't do it don't don't
don't say anything don't say any man
come on and he was like don't it's just
what happens this is what happens you
don't want as a game you don't want to
make a thing about it because it you
don't understand it you don't have
context for it but I was like your boy
my mother came oh yeah or for like you
know parent there when I'm telling I'm
more right to my mother go hey guess
what that guy did this that and the
other thing he also did this they
brought all of us in all of us told I
remember I never forgot the owner the
camp said now I'm gonna ask you some
questions I don't want to get emotional
about it did he put his mouth here he
asked me all kinds of question I said no
but he did it to Donny and they brought
Donnie and Donnie was like [ __ ] you
know he was sensitive
I wasn't dude I wasn't your socio but
I'm not a sensitive guy dead behind yeah
you know I am I'm not sensitive I don't
know why I'm just not that my other
friend was and I did honey was crying
yeah and I wasn't and again maybe I
would have been but I wasn't raped
and there's a difference like I said
some kids you can't come back from that
especially when it's a priest or or
somebody that that is a pillar of the
baby so what you don't know where to
turn what they do to the camp oh oh
that's was the seventies blah blah you
know what they told he was made promoted
he was married you know his wife said
because my mother said this to me
his wife said oh god he's up to that
again oh my god and she was the
arts-and-crafts team's his nemesis and
this is why this this is why this me to
thing is a good thing because it's
raising awareness for people who really
have been traumatized and abused and so
what happened was he goes um and then
they just he just was moved on back then
there's no database there's no like you
know he was just moved on I don't know
what happened
so Chris as a as a because you didn't
read about this stuff as a boy as a
mother as you didn't think it was that
big a deal because it was just a creepy
guy from a different time but you know
what I mean you do because we back then
what did you know about kids getting
abducted would you say about that stuff
would your dad thick because if I always
came home from school my dad my teacher
mr. Blake yes my dick my dad once what's
his name yeah what a Martin my father
was overseas and I bet and then you
asked me for the first time I just never
think about this I bet you my mother
never told him and I bet you he still
doesn't know he knows now yeah I bet you
my mom never told him but because that
would serve no good but back then by the
way can you imagine the lawsuit now that
was never even brought up back then no
one sued back then now we're all sue yep
no no you didn't sue you didn't know
about child abduction you didn't know
about perversion you didn't none of this
stuff was talked about I'm old enough to
remember this none of this stuff was and
it was it was what he was considered to
be was the same as a peeping tom or a
flasher or that that's kind of everybody
all those weirdos were put in the
context my sister came home and this guy
asked her to touch his dick and said
it's a red balloon and she I remember we
had to talk about in the family this was
in Greece when over there back in 76 or
something so again these were things
that you you didn't hear about the
stories of child abduction of child
Leone you heard about a creep who jerked
off in a car you don't have any problems
chin no close calls I don't think so so
we don't remember stuff like Jonathan
height you know the social psychologist
was on Rogan he said back in the day
kids were allowed to walk to school they
were allowed to do everything on their
own they could play and everything else
then in the eighties there there were
some high-profile child abductions
and the details came out like John Wayne
Gacy about what he did Ted Bundy and all
of a sudden we found out that there were
very evil people out there who got off
on killing torturing and raping women
children and and Jonathan Hyde does a
really good job of showing this when
kids start showing up on milk cartons
you had a generation of helicopter
parents oh yeah and all of a sudden
parents like you I'm Gil like me we
don't let our kids go to the store we
don't let our kids walk home we don't
let our kids ever be alone and
unsupervised and and and what is done is
its created a lot of anxiety in children
a lot of a lack of independence it's
created kids who always have somebody
watching over them so they don't settle
things on their own what they do is they
go to the authority figure and it's
caused a lot of damage and we'll do live
in though how many how many kids are
abducted by strangers a year
couldn't tell you number I have no idea
100 very very few it's very good [ __ ]
rare god damn right it's good I've
always been very loosey goosey always
been very rare but you pay a price too
for being having a hell on either way
though well listen either way listen
it's our worst nightmare it's every
parent's worst nightmare why would I
give that to you as it's a gift it's a
gift